(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Olá, meu nome é Priscila Perini, seja muito
bem-vindo ao curso Vivendo de Leilão.
Antes de mais nada, gostaria de agradecer a
confiança que você depositou em meu trabalho e
também te parabenizar por optar estudar uma área
tão desconhecida pela maioria da população.
Os leilões de imóveis são uma grande oportunidade
de investimento ou até mesmo para realizar o
sonho da casa própria.
Leilão não é um bicho de sete cabeças
como muitas pessoas tentam espalhar por aí e
até peço que você desconfie das pessoas que
falem mal de leilão porque tem muita gente
lucrando muito alto nesse mercado.
Esse mercado, ele ainda é bem inexplorado.
Existem leilões todos os dias que encerram de
forma negativa, ou seja, sem nenhum lance.
Então tem muito espaço para crescimento e muito
espaço para que várias pessoas possam aproveitar excelentes
oportunidades.
Durante o curso, nós vamos passar por todos
os procedimentos que você deve analisar antes de
participar de um leilão, durante o leilão e
após o leilão.
Essa é a forma mais lucrativa de você
participar de um leilão de imóvel.
Por quê?
Porque existem várias consultorias especializadas em leilão espalhadas
pelo país.
Mas essas consultorias cobram em média de 7
% a 10% do valor de cada
arrematação para realizar seu serviço.
Em que consistiria o serviço de uma consultoria?
A consultoria encontra oportunidade de leilão, analisa a
documentação do imóvel e do leilão, realiza o
lance e depois cuida de uma eventual desocupação.
Ou seja, a consultoria, ela não vende o
imóvel para o arrematante.
Então, você como arrematante, aprendendo a escolher a
melhor oportunidade, analisar toda a documentação e realizar
seu lance, mesmo que para a eventual desocupação
você precise de um auxílio de um advogado,
isso vai te custar muito mais barato.
Dependendo do valor do imóvel, você não vai
pagar a títulos de honorários para cuidar de
uma desocupação nem 1% do valor da
arrematação.
E aqui eu queria fazer uma ressalva.
Mesmo que você contraste uma consultoria, caso você
participe de um leilão excrediticial, por exemplo, essa
consultoria, no primeiro passo da desocupação, ela vai
tentar um acordo com quem está ocupando aquele
imóvel.
E esse acordo não é feito através da
justiça.
Esse acordo é um acordo excrediticial.
Então, nada impede que você como arrematante realize
esse acordo excrediticial e nem mesmo precise de
um advogado.
Pode ser então que você não precise de
advogado nenhum durante a sua caminhada nos leilões
de imóveis.
O curso está dividido em quatro módulos, sendo
o primeiro módulo de conhecimentos gerais sobre os
leilões, o segundo módulo sobre os leilões extrajudiciais,
o terceiro módulo sobre os leilões judiciais e
o quarto módulo sobre questões pós-arrematação que
você também precisa conhecer.
O curso com essa divisão segue uma lógica
didática para te auxiliar na melhor compreensão de
todos os pontos.
Pode ser que durante uma análise de um
edital de um leilão, de uma matrícula de
um imóvel, você se depare com termos jurídicos
e pode ser que você não conheça esses
termos.
Não precisa ficar preocupado, nós vamos passar aqui
durante o curso em todos os termos que
você pode encontrar e qual é a aplicação
prática de existir um termo na documentação de
um imóvel específico que seja do seu interesse.
Nesse primeiro momento, você só tem acesso a
essa aula de boas-vindas, mas você já
pode analisar a sua área de membros da
Hotmart e verificar a divisão do curso, a
divisão de cada aula dentro de cada módulo
e o tema central de cada aula.
Cada aula tem um tema central e esse
tema é o nome da aula.
Então você já pode verificar em qual aula
específica você aprenderá determinado ponto que possa ser
do seu maior interesse.
As aulas na Hotmart serão liberadas de forma
gradual, sendo um módulo por semana no começo
de cada semana.
Então o curso será liberado ao final de
quatro semanas.
Apesar desse prazo de liberação do curso, as
aulas vão ficar disponíveis sem qualquer prazo de
expiração.
Então a finalidade do curso é justamente que
você assista ao curso e que você possa
recorrer ao curso quantas vezes você quiser, porque
as aulas vão estar lá sempre disponíveis para
que você possa fazer sua consulta.
Então pode ser que você tenha assistido o
curso uma primeira vez e na hora de
colocar o seu conhecimento em prática, de efetivamente
participar de um leilão, você se depare com
um termo que você não lembra mais o
que significa e qual é a consequência prática
daquele termo.
Isso não tem qualquer problema.
Basta que você volte à aula específica daquele
termo para relembrar todo o conteúdo.
Além da plataforma aqui da Hotmart, nós teremos
um grupo fechado dos alunos no Facebook.
Esse grupo vai ser a nossa central de
dúvidas, onde eu vou poder interagir diretamente com
vocês, responder diretamente a sua pergunta e também
vai servir para que eu realize lives semanais
sobre temas específicos e até mesmo tirar as
dúvidas mais frequentes dos alunos.
O curso, então, vai ser liberado ao total
de quatro semanas e o nosso grupo no
Facebook vai ter uma duração de cinco semanas
para que vocês possam assistir tranquilamente todas as
aulas e possam me mandar qualquer dúvida que
exista sobre algum tema específico.
Então, tem essa semana bônus justamente para que
você não saia do curso com nenhuma dúvida.
É isso.
Agradeço mais uma vez a confiança que você
depositou no meu trabalho.
Seja muito bem-vindo ao curso Vivendo de
Leilão.